et j'ai pas le temps pendant la semaine
de de faire le marché chaque jour alors
je j'ai fais un grand marché le samedi
et après je j'achète des petites choses
pendant la semaine mais c'est pas une
manière de vivre à la française
[Musique]
ça je m'appelle j j'avais 21 ans quand
on a tourné ce film l'année dernière je
m'appelle Bill et j'avais 28 ans qu'on a
tourné ce
film venait de r Oui j'ai enseigné
là-bas comme
l'acteur comment c'est passé ce voyage
c'est bien comme toujours beaucoup
d'élèves non pas beaucoup
Clement c'est de moins en moins
maintenant
jusquau
j' organis des programmes éducatif pour
des améric en
Europe qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
maintenant je retourne chez
moi et puis je ne sais pas faire le
dîner peutre et moi nous IR au cinéma je
sais
pas vous allez faire comme
dîner vous enseignez à qui c'est les
étudiants français au Faculté des
lettres qui faitent des étudesanglais et
a aussi les études américaines et vous
le enseignez quoi bon c'est la
littérature et histoire de la musique en
Amérique quand vous rentrez chez vous B
est en train de jouer de l'or oui
toujours et je frappe à la porte et
s'arrête et puis c'est fini pour vous
l'entendez quand vous montez les
oui toujours même au 3è étage qu'est-ce
que vous faites maintenant vous allez
faire maintenant oh je travaill l un
peuù je je taper un peu la TSE ça dépend
où est-ce que c'est
c'estici c'est toujours là ah non nous
habit près de maintenant ça beaucoup
changé les beaux
[Musique]
quartiersin
ça te fait de revoir
l'appartement c'est trop qu'on pense
qu'on habite tout là
c'est disccret de vous demander un peu
de de quoi il est question dans cette
lettre ah non pas du tout c'est de qui
de votre mère oui ma mère elle dit qu'
ma sœur avait son anniversaire hier
alors c'est une lre à toi alors elle dit
que bon anniversaire elle elle a 18 ans
maintenant elle dit 18 ans vraiment on
peut être tué au Vietnam pour les
garç un garç mais
elle est content que n'est pas un garçon
pour cette
raison vous ne regrettez pas un peu ce
quartier beaucoup les les commerçants
étaient très gentil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
pour pourquoi vous améicaniser comme ça
à Paris parce que je trava j'ai pas le
temps
semire Mar alors grand March le samedi
et après j'achète des petites choses
pendant la semaine c'est pas une manière
de vivre à la française ça vous vous
parlez mais t les femmes chez le bureau
qui sont français exactement même chose
et dis-moi mais mais les petits
commerçants est-ce qu'il y en a
là-bas les petits commerçants avec qui
on fait la conversation
oui dans les gâteau oui dans les g-ce
que tu appelles les
gâteau
ville les gâteaux les gâteau des noirs
ou des Italiens ou des Juifs ouais et
moi par exemple en broston j'ai chaque
semaine j'ai j'ai fait ma marché sur le
gâteau italien parce qu'on peut acheter
des choses on peut pas dans ce supermché
et là tu parles un peu avec les gens ah
oui bien sûr on
dit Mame
2395ve quelqu fois des clients
américains quelqu
fois en général les Américains sont très
gentil
ah c'est par sont là vous dites ça ou
c'est
c'est un peu mon c'est vrai quand
[Musique]
même aussi ça vous manque hein oui ah
oui ah oui la rue là c'est mais ça a
changé un peu peut-être parce que les
n'est plus là je sais
pas est-ce que vous pouvez essayer de me
dire pourquoi la vie américaine est
agréable ou l' pas j'en sais rien la vie
quotidienne euh pourquoi c'est agréable
pourquoi ça ne l' pas ça m égal de c'est
agréable parce que c'est beaucoup plus
facile euh si on fait les cours ça prend
un demi de temps on peut faire la
vaisselle pour les vêtements ça prend un
demi de temps alors on a beaucoup plus
temps libre pour cette raison c'est plus
agréable mais à l'autre côté c'est pas
des c'est pas agréable parce que les
gens qui a tout ce temps ne savoir pas
comment
apprécier alors et c'est dommage les
gens ne sa ne savent pas comment être
relaxé et je ne sais pas mais on dit que
beaucoup des hommes se m des crises
ciaques parce qu'on travaille trop les
hommes j'aime pas cette impression
ici je sais pas non mais écoutez vous
dites vous dites à Paris oui c'est vrai
toutes les grandes villes alors
finalement quel est l'avantage de vivre
à Paris si vous y retrouvez ce que vous
trouvez aux États-Unis
oh Paris beau paril
français je ne sais pasétiquette d'être
français c'est pas ça qui rend les
choses plus belles ou meilleur non mais
c'est toujours bien d'être un étranger à
notre
ville vous aviez été invité chez un un
haut dirigeant je crois d'une société
américaine en France oui oui c'est ça
c'est un bel appartement
très il n'y a pas de ville que je
connaisse et je connais pas mal de
capital il n a pas de ville qui a cette
beauté d'arbre qu'il y a à Paris les les
les jeunes gens là sont à Paris depuis
combien de temps 1 an et demi 1 an demi
et vous vous connaissez Paris depuis
combien temp 1915 ça
fait on pas quand j'étais jeune il y
avait comme un trait en plus de ce qu'il
y a à Paris aujourd'hui il y avait des
papes il y avait Picasso il y a toujours
Picasso mais il y avait Picasso en
pleine éclosion explosion
de son talent d'homme il y avait Gertrud
Stein il y avait que dirais-je encore il
y avait
Bourdel MAOL et bien ces papes attiré
toute une génération d'Américains
qui qui navigaient autour d'eux qui
vivaient de leur souffle ça ça n'existe
plus vous allez leur donner le regret de
pas être ten 30 ans plus tôt et bien
c'est le rôle de tout vieillard
ça fait de TR fois que je vous entends
dire nous les étrangers moi l'étranger
ça fait 50 ans que vous habitez Paris à
peu près oui avec des ABS on rest
toujours
étrang je vais vous dire si j'entends
des Français qui attaquent les
américain ça arrive vous sentez
américain alors je suis 100% américain
j'ai réagi violemment mais si j'entends
des Américains qui attaquent la France
je dis mais vous n'y comprenez
absolument rien et je suis 100 %
français alors maintenant le matin c'est
en ascenseur ah
oui quand ça
marche j'ai j'ai choisi g parce que elle
est une individuelle c'est une dame qui
a ses ses idées
propreselle ê très intellectuelle elle
aime les
idées pour moi c'est très bien parce que
elle est très gentil avec moi elle a
de confiance c'est très c'est très
important pour un homme je crois et mais
aussi parce qu'elle est très belle
bonjour
monsieur autre fois j'ai pensé que
c'était un faute que qu'elle n'était pas
gentil avec quelqu'un qui elle n'aime
pas mais maintenant euh je trouve ça
très pratique tu penses toujours la même
chose maintenant oh oui à peu près oui
c'est
vrai moi je je trouve qu'il est très
gentil très intéressant et ce que j'aime
le mieux il a un très bon sens tu meurs
nous
[Musique]
beaucoup tu servais de guide à un groupe
de jeunes filles c'est ça oui c'est ça
des étudiants de mais est beaucoup plus
gentil que moi moi je suis
comment je peux pas être gentil Toutant
il a des moments que je déteste les gens
mais lui il peut peut gentil à quelqu'un
même siil n'aime pas et moi si je n'aime
pas quelqu'un je lui fais savoir
pourquoi je trouve qu'il il aime trop la
sécurité et ça me
gne qu'est-ce que tu as ajouté
maintenant je trouve qu'il a changé il a
moins de
sécuriténe ah B bonjour
very nice to meet you hope you' having a
good time here in
Paris and uh then we have a nice little
rabbit here for for the Jo you see a
little standup model it sits up right by
right
byself you want see one
funny the day that we were married my
greatest
quand les gens arrivent ici les jeunes
gens arrivent ici en Europe la plupart
des temps ils connaissent personne donc
il faut il faut vraiment travailler il
faut compter ce soi même si on est un
peu malade ou triste pour une raison ou
pour une autre il n a pas la petit MAM
qui est à côté ou le papa qui peut vous
donner quelques centaines de francs mais
vous devez vous même trouver les
débouchés j'ai travaillé dans une
cuisine Orte pour encore gagner quelqu
repas parce que j'avais presque plus
rien à ce momentl quand je suis arrivé
ici en Europe j'étais primo touriste et
ensuite au début 62 j'ai commencé avec
l' en société américan sur place ici à
Paris comme vendeur de pote à pote et
ensuite après à peu près un an j'étais
nommé directeur de de publicité et
promotion de vente pour cette société en
Belgique et pour la simple raison que le
directeur de de cette compagnie ne
voulait pas grimper plus haut
euh j'ai décidé j'ai pris un risque de
quitter la compagnie de commencer les
études d'allemand pour me perfectionner
et pourmer plus haut plus tard et
ensuite d'aller à Ina dans l'institut
européen d'administration des affaires à
Fontainbleau
euh c'était si vous voulez un grand
risque je courrais mais en fin de compte
j'ai réalisé une augmentation de salaire
de 50 %. qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce
que vous en
pensez vous êtes américains après touti
oui oui oui oui et je trouve qu'il est
typiquement l'homme businessman
américain qui qui pense comment on peut
monter comment on peut réussir avec le
travail mais c'est pas c'est pas ce
genre d'américain que vous avez envie
d'être vous ça n'est pas ce type
d'américain que vous avez envie d'être
non non pas moi non non non je pense à
autre chose que
pour je pense pas seulement oui
pour gagner la vie et tout
ça ce morceau d'or c'est toi aussi
oui ton professeur c'était je
l'anglais C chez
[Musique]
lui
l'anglais est-ce que Bill est un bon
élève oh excellent très
sérieux très sérieux comme beaucoup
d'Américains d'ailleurs j'oserais même
dire comme tous pourquoi à votre avis
mais parce que ils viennent en France
pour apprendre ils apprennent qu'est-ce
que vous allez travailler aujourd'hui et
bien nous allons jouer mon poème of Life
qui est une pièce que j'ai écrite en
65 ainsi comme vous le voyez le titre
est américain l'éditeur est américain
l'exécutant est
américain vous pensez vraiment qu'il y a
une sorte de dessin de l'américain il
soit différent de l' du dessin du
français ah oui oui certainement je
crois qu'ils sont ils n'ont pas de
complexe en général voyez-vous les
Américains moi quand je me trouve avec
avec Darius mot qui est un grand maître
je me sens extrêmement complexé n'est-ce
pas mais eux pas du tout d'ailleurs j'ai
été le voir Darius m il enseigne làbas à
MS College B on l'appelle
Darius les Américains vous accueillent à
bras ouvert n'est-ce pas mais la plupart
d'entre eux vous oublient aussi à bras
ouvert ils en accueillent d'autres après
ça c'est ça les nouveaux chassent les
premiers j'ai l'impression que
finalement vous att chez plus
d'importance à l'arrangement de la
nourriture qu' la nourriture elle-même
non ça vous pas ça vous a pas un peu
choqué l'importance que les Français
attachent à la nourriture quand vous
êtes arrivés en
France non oh mais oui oui de trouver
que tout le monde ici comme
j' que tout le monde dans le me pense
que j'étais fou pourquoi Paul parce que
moi je trouve que c'est important ma
nourriture il faut il faut penser mais
là-bas on mange pour
vivre pas vivre pour mange
manger que sont-ils devenus ils sont à
Boston maintenant lui il ensene à
Harvard et elle s'occupe des finances
pour des des noirs pour des mouvements
noirs
[Musique]
oui
parce que je crois que les Français
pensent que le problème de couleur est
quelqu'un qui est très noir ou très
foncé mais ce n'est pas ça parce qu'aux
États-Unis même si quelqu'un est un tout
petit peu de couleur ça c'est un noir
et je pense que peut-être c'est plus
grave que qu'on pense maintenant parce
que il faut attendre l'été pour voir les
choses qu'on va faire mais
mais c'est une euh pour moi c'est une
chose très nécessaire pour monte à les
États-Unis les POP les États-Unis quelqu
situation qui est très très très mal et
que le le les États-Unis ne veut pas
voir mais je trouve aussi par exemple
l'Afrique du Sud le question
est est aussi p et et moi je trouve que
c'est pas dans Amérique somement que
cette problème
existe moi non tout ce que je veux dire
c'est que je trouve que la situation est
extrêmement grave mais je trouve ce que
ce qui disait tout à fait au
commencement c'est les Français ne
comprennent pas parce qu'il n'y a pas de
problème équivalent il y a des problèmes
de racisme qui existent en France mais
c'est des des gens qui viennent c'est
des étrangers c'està dire c'est ou bien
des des gens de l'Afrique du Nord ou
bien des des Africains enfin noirs il y
a pas de problème avec une population
indigène en France alors ils ont
l'air le les Français comprennent pas le
problème et le problème je trouve est
assez bien représenté dans la presse
française enfin je parle du monde quoi
enfin mais
euh vous voyez ce que je veux dire
est-ce que je m'explique
bien je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
parce que il n'y a pas un problème de
préjudice de couleur en France mais
quand même je crois il y a un problème
de préjudice social préjudice préjé
préjusé social oui et souvent je crois
les Français dit il n'y a pas de un
système racial mais il y a un système
social qui je pense est aussi pire par
exemple pour les gens qui ne gagn pas
beaucoup et les gens d'autres pays qui
viennent en France pour travailler je
crois il y a un sentiment contre ces
gens par exemple des des espagnols ou
des
Italiens oui qui travaillent avec des
petites le bon fait rejou
le
rejouir le
cœur rejouir le bon rejouir le cœur
c'est
que o est-ce qu'elle en est cette
t en est oui tu l'as fini bientôt
j'espère dans dans 2 mois j'espère
d'avoir fini première version mais j'ai
beaucoup c'est quoi déjà le sujet c'est
un une organice du 17e siècle et
maintenant je suis j'ai
écrit tout sur Louis et maintenant
j'écris de pour la musique après Louis
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais tu tu fais
simplement une biographie ou tu tires
des conclusions euh j'ai fait un
histoire la musique drog avant luoui un
biographie de Louis un bibliographie de
ces et puis j'ai parlé
de et alors maintenant fini cette thèse
oui oui c'est accepté oui tu lui en
donnes tous les jours comme ça un petit
non mais il a pas de travaillé pour 2
mois alors ça c'est une faête tu es
docteur maintenant oui au fond cette
thèse ça va te mener à quoi
ah après j'ai j'aurai un doctorat
et et qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre il y a
encore des choses non ah je sais pas
vous vous regardez je suis plus j'ai
plus d'intérêt de de faire quelque chose
avec les questions raciales aux
États-Unis maintenant mais peut-être
quelque chose dans la musique avec la
mus avec la musique oui pour peut-être
pour enseigner des noirs ou quelque
chose comme ça parce que c'est un parti
les Noirs pe gagner très bien la vie
avec la musique et peut-être je peux
aider un peu je sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas
qu'estce que tu lui racontais j'étais
ici hier soir et j'ai vu les étudiants
qui qui enlèv les pierres et j'ai
raconté la façon le fait avec
[Musique]
les le fer autour des arbres on enlève
ça
[Musique]
et
tu m'as dit aussi que tu avais
l'impression ici que la population était
était très en faveur des étudiants et ça
t'étonnait ah
oui un peu dans le journal on a dit que
plus que 50% pense que que les étudiants
raison parce qu'en Amérique tout le
monde pense que les étudiants sont sont
des communistes s'en
fout ça qui s'en fout et que les jeunes
ne peuvent pas avoir des idées qui sont
babes ça on dit ça mais t les jeunes
peut pas savoir ça tu me raconter aussi
que en Amérique les les les gens
auraient été très malheureux à propos de
leur voiture non ah oui on pense que le
la propriété c'est la la chose la plus
important on peut pas on peut
tirer à quelqu'un qui qui a brisé une
glace ou quelque chose comme ça il y a
beaucoup qui pensent que c'est c'est
raisonnable et c'est c'est pourquoi en
Amérique il a une manifestation il a des
voitures des des fenêtres qui sont
cassées les gens n' pas du tout de
sympathie avec des des gens
[Musique]
qui je
pense dans l'avenir il faut retourner en
Amérique parce que ici à Paris nous nous
nous échappons
tout les vrais problèmes en pense mais
c'est vous vous sentez désengagé ici PE
d'être ici oui et je crois pour la vie
entière il faut être engagé un
peu quelle peut être la dans la place de
votre vie familiale
enfin une situation très bien dans une
grand ville mais où nous pouvons voyager
chaque été et prendre des années de
temps en temps pour vivre
ici et on veut retourner quand nous nous
avons des enfants pour que les enfants
peuent parler le français
avec très bon accent mieux que nous
justement les enfant c'est c'est comme
ça enfin je veux dire ça ça ne semble
pas
être une chose primordiale pour vous
avoir des enfants je veux dire vous nees
pas ensemble pour avoir des enfants oh
c'est difficile à ce moment parce
que nous n'avons pas une situation qui
qui est très
pour les enfants mais en quelques année
oui ah nous voudons de d'avoir peut-être
deux enfants et d'adopter les nous nous
voudrions avoir une famille
internationale c'est-à-dire de d'avoir
deux enfants et adopter un noir un
oriental et peut-être bon et maintenant
nous avons commencé à faire des
démarches parce que la l'été que nous
sommes mariés j'ai travaillé dans un
hôpital et j'ai vu tout le temps des
enfants noirs surtout qui sont
abandonnés alors je me disais
que si on pense vraiment les les les
enfants blancs sont facilement adoptés
mais jamais personne veut enfant
[Applaudissements]
noir
qui ét ces jeunes filles c'était un
groupe de jeunes filles noir qui ont
ellmême recueillli l'argent pour venir
en Europe comment ont fait ont organisé
des bars ont même vendu des gâteaux ont
chant et C je que c'est groupe
quiissance une inititive c'est très rare
que ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrive pe voir qu'ils sont très jeunes
sont entre 14 et 17 ans et il y a
quelquesunes qui ont déjà des
enfants
l hab bidon ville à newen
connetic et comme elle disait ils
appartiennent à des familles très
nombreuses
qu'est-ce que vous voulez
obtenir c'est Monsieur Robert Jones
l'animateur de ce groupe lui et tout ce
groupe fait partie d'une centre plus
large à newen et comme enfin ce voyage
est un exemple comme il essaie de
favoriser les la promotion sociale des
noirs et du de le permettre de prendre
charge le propre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
destin alors on en est là c'est vu comme
çaoui TR
moments alors je sais pas peut peut-être
essayer de définir votre
avenir B bon
som ton avenir immédiat c'estans
oui à ce à ce niveau ici maintenant
maintenant on attend parce que j'ai
demandé on est en train de de faire un
collège en université à mon alors
finalement tu n'as pas ce poste là
maintenant qu'est-ce que tu fais
maintenant bon j'ai enseigné à
Vincen à l'université de Vincen oui
c'est ça c'est pas l'avenir chérie c'est
c'est seulement que tu cherches travail
ah qu'est-ce que c'est alors ça veut
dire ah bon elle a le plan gigantique
non je crois au point de vue de l'avenir
euh allez bse-moi ton avenir pour euh
c'est ça moi je m'en fous de l'avenir je
pense si je peux pense même à l'année
prochaine ça c'est que c'est quand même
quelque chose et je crois que ça c'est
plutôt d'être jeune que américaine
français je crois que à cet âge on peut
pas penser aux années prochaine oui
alors toi maintenant tu veux essayer
d'être actrice oui c'est ça il y a pas
mal des gens qui changent du métier à
l'âge de 40 ans des choses comme ça ça
paraîtras normal ça oui aux États-Unis
surtout maintenant c'est c'est normal
pour un homme de gagner beaucoup
d'argent avant qu'il a 40 ans et puis de
de trouver qu'il n'aime pas qu'il n'est
pas content et tout ça et puis quitter
tout ça et faire quelque chose d'autre
tu serais capable de ça toi oh mais je
le fais tout les
années mais tu ça avec la peinture oui
oui et toi
oui je peux le faire surtout travailler
avec des des gens pauvres des des gens
noirs
des moi je pense au problème d'Amérique
c'est pour ça tu es pas en train de
vouloir faire de la charité là non je ne
pas dire ça parce que je crois que des
gens qui voudraient faire des charités
peuv faire beaucoup de mal mais c'est
c'est une idée de tu suis t cours et tu
étudia un peu des des des problèmes qui
existent dans un pays et puis tu es prêt
de de faire quelque chose je crois que
c'est ma vie je veux je voudrais faire
quelque chose alors ENF ici en à Paris
vous avez rien qu'est-ce que vous avez
ici quelque chose moins matériel quoi
oui ah bon ici je sais pas la jeunesse
n nous avons nous nous avons
Paris ça on dirait un mot de la fin ça
non nous avons Paris comme ça oui des
belles majuscules ou ah oui mais c'est
c'est ça que on a Paris c'est comme
comme à Paris on a beaucoup de choses à
faire on fait pas beaucoup de choses
tout le temps tout le temps mais on sait
que qu'ils sont là peut j les faire oui
on peut un jour les faire pu après on
dit oh mais on n pas fait ceci
cela mais c'est bien de viv dans un pays
o même si on ne parle pas très bien on
peut on peut faire des amis parce qu'on
peut parler français et je crois que
aussi ça ça c'est important les amis
français oui vous ai amené des amis
comme ça ou que ce soit des Américains
ou des Français immédiatement
l'impression que vous vous connaissiez
depuis depuis un an ah mais c'est mais
c'est le caractère
américain de de faire les amis très vite
de faire des connaissances de faire les
connaissances très vite oui et puis et
puis on verra ça tu veux le garder ce
côtélà oui oui parce que moi je sais
nous invitons tout le temps des amis de
dîner ici mais les des fois que les
Français nous invitent dîner chez eux
c'est beaucoup moins souvent oui parce
que à ce momentl on sait qu'on est un
vrai ami
quoi tu as parlé de dîner vous avez faim
non
oui
s oui alors on se quitte
oui je me sens triste mais il fautut oui
fa finir un bonjour un
bonjour Alors on dit comme ça on dit
qu'on
finit et après 20 ans on peut faire are
émission 20 ans avec et
[Musique]
voilà
y